the question again is why does all of
this keep happening why does the race
stuff keep happening why does the gender
stuff keep happening why does the open
border stuff keep happening well there
actually is a reason for it this video
has been making the rounds it's from
2017 and it is the CEO of BlackRock
Larry Fink along with the CEO of Amex
American Express
explaining how they basically use their
conglomerates to quote Force behaviors
on people this is wild and remember this
is about six seven years ago so think
about what we've been through for the
last six seven years now listen to this
you you now make a point of that's
that's an investment criteria for you
well behaviors are going to have to
change and this is one thing we're gonna
we're asking companies
you have to force behaviors and at
BlackRock we are forcing behaviors 54 of
the incoming class are women we we added
four more points in terms of diverse uh
employment this year and it will if it
you know what we're doing internally is
if you don't achieve these levels of
impact your compensation could be
impacted okay we're doing the same thing
so it's just you have to force behaviors
and if you don't force behaviors whether
it's gender or race or just any way you
want to say the composition of your team
you're going to be impacted and that's
not just not recruiting it is
development as Ken said and ultimately
it's still going to take time but I am
just as much shocked as Ken is that we
have not
seen more opportunities and we're going
to have to force change how do you get
it guys Force change Force behaviors
Larry Fink by the way has been the CEO
of BlackRock I think since 1988 he is
still the CEO of BlackRock he is a white
man I looks like in in maybe his early
to mid 60s has not stepped down for a
black lesbian yet it's very very bizarre
I thought change starts with you the man
in the mirror what are you doing dude
but now do you get it so these companies
that then push these crazy policies on
all of their subsidiaries are actually
injecting racism injecting gender
discrimination against say straight
people etc etc into all these things so
there's a clean path right that's what
I'm trying to lay out to you guys today
when every day we wake up and there's
more craziness or why does the craziness
never stop there's a there's a clear
reason for it
[Music]
foreign